qu'est ce que vous voulez 9 juillet que
pendant la chanson kelly va révéler quel
est ton équipe sexuelle totale sur
alonso non oui mais normalement il a il
devait aller chez le bon ok mais je
pense qu'il va annuler alors est-ce
qu'on peut le faire venir dans un
instant alonso et vous on rappelle que
vous êtes en quête total sur delphine
wespiser un jour voilà et vous avez-vous
expressément soir la baisse du prof
d'histoire-géo wall et c'est la baisse
note à destelbergen bakaba tout à fait
du seul japon
on attend l'arrivée dans l'instant moi
je suis alors ml c'est comme ma soeur
est le voilà désormais on se voit tous
les jours
oui j'ai une grande famille et alors oui
il arrive sur ma gauche on va dialoguer
alonso mais ils arriveront sur ma gauche
il est allé il est allé sur il est allé
sur un autre plateau va
[Applaudissements]
les cfc
alors je te dis la vérité tt normalement
tu dois revenir dans l'émission y'a d'la
il ya eu ce qu'on appelle dans le milieu
du sexe un flash et benneteau c'est à
dire qu'il ya une personne ici présentes
sur le plateau qui en plus célibataire
on va pas se mentir c'est quelqu'un qui
cherche l'amour d'ailleurs on peut le
voir sur son chemiser il y à une
personne qui a flashé sur toi ok ça
n'est pas la plus moche ah non d'accord
déjà alonso tu sais que je t'aime
beaucoup
première question bien entendu
importante où on est tu senti
mentalement et je pense que tout le
monde public le chu henri mondor
[Applaudissements]
je suis venu te vois pas ce que je
voulais tous prêtés je vais t'en fais
pas la monnaie c'est vrai c'est
franchement babeau alors sachez en tout
cas que tu sais c'est des mariés will et
tu sais c'est pas parce qu'on a une
voiture qu'on n'a pas le droit de
regarder les autres en vitrine monaco
alonso autres cac et d'items beaucoup
ont dit oui bien sûr je suis son public
et je suis au courant et c'était de
l'admiration parce que je trouve qu'il a
beaucoup trop de style adore ses
musiques et ses taux bas voilà et en
rattrapage a fait la femme samantha
samatan gbagbo et voilà et moi voilà moi
je te kiffe mais c'est que de l'amitié
je viens d'entendre sans merci
[Applaudissements]